وحش افلاس بنك سيليكون فالي مستمر في
اثاره الذعر حول العالم وترامب يصف مرشح
رئاسي بالكلب وبفضل رونالدو النصر يتفوق
على كبار انديه اوروبا اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من ايامه لسه هو العنوان الابرز والاول في
الاخبار والمواقع والمنصات وحقيقه كميه
الفريدز للواحد قريها عن الموضوع الايام
الماضيه على تويتر غير طبيعيه طبعا بتكلم
عن خبر افلاس بنك سيليكون فالي واللي ممكن
جدا نسميه وحش افلاس بنك سلك فاللي فعليا
صار او جالس يصير على المنصات ما فينا
نسميه الا حاله من الرعب والهلع هذا من
ناحيه الافراد والمختصين ومن ناحيه
الحكومات والدول الدنيا كمان مقلوبه
تصريحات وتقوينات وتدخلات وفعليا بنك ما
كنا سمعنا فيه من قبل على الاقل يعني احنا
كناس مو مختصه في الاقتصاد فجاه صرنا نشوف
رئيس اكبر دوله في العالم طالع بكلمه خاصه
عنه وحكومات بريطانيا والمانيا وغيرها
بتتكلم عنه واجراءات وحسابات وسيل من
الاخبار فعليا احنا من كم يوم تناولنا
معكم بالموضوع وبسطناه على قد ما نقدر
يعني لنا وللمشاهد يعني وشرحنا ازمه البنك
الحاليه لكن اليوم لسه في تساؤلات خاصه
وان الموضوع جالس يتطور اولا في تضارب او
خناجات اونلاين بين كثير ناس هذا بنك
عملاق او لا الناس تقول ايه ناس تقول لا
ثانيا ليه كل هذه الدوله او ياكل هذه
الدول تحديدا متدخله في الموضوع وماخذ هذه
الابعاد السياسيه هل المفروض اللي بيصير
حاليا هذه يخوفنا احنا كافراد عاديين يعني
اللي هم لا مستثمرين ولا شيء ثالثا وقبل
كل هذا انا كشخص عادي مو مستثمر حاطط
فلوسي
المتواضعه في بنك كيف اضمن امانها كيف
اضمن انه البنك بيستثمرها صح وما رح يصير
لها شيء بعد الاشياء اللي احنا جالسين
نسمعها رح تساعدنا في الاجابه على هذه
الاسئله زميلتنا في قسم الاقتصاد لارا
حبيب اهلا فيك معانا يا لارا منوره
بالاحمر لون غير محبب عندكم
طيب البنك يعني هو هذا
كبير اللي عامل الضجه دي كلها
هو بنك بدك تعتبريه هيدا بنك ستارتبس
شركات الناشئه بقى كل الشركات الناشئه
وتتجمع كثير مصاري من الفانز بنسميهم اللي
بيدعموا شركات الناشئه بتروح بتحط
هالاموال بمصرف اس بي بي بقى بدك تشوفي
انه هو تقريبا عنده كونسنتريشن من نوع
معين من تركيز يعني عنده تركيز من نوع
معين من العملاء لذلك صار في داعي هن
صاروا يخبروا بعضهم انه هذا المصرف عنده
بعض المشاكل صار في دار ركضوا تيسحبوا
اموالهم من هذا المصرف علما انه اي وديعه
فوق ال 250 الف دولار
هي غير مضمونه من الجهات التنظيميه في
الولايات المتحده في كثير من هول الشركات
كان عندهم ودائع اكثر بكثير يعني في شركات
مثلا سبوتيفاي كان عندها وديعه هونيك
شركات تكنولوجيا معروفه عندها لانه هذا
بقدم خدمات مصرفيه البنوك العاديه بنوك
العاديه ما بتقدمها لهيك صار في دعار ولا
هيك صار فيه سحوبات كبيره امس شفنا كميه
بيانات كبيره يعني طلع الرئيس بايدن في
خطاب شفنا الحكومه
البريطانيه الحكومه الالمانيه شفنا بعدين
ظهورك على الهواء فتحت الاسواق الامريكيه
والتغطيتك للموضوع وشفنا الانخفاض اللي
كان جالس بيصير ليش
حكومات كبيره في هذا الموضوع لانه دائما
بيخافوا انه نحن نرجع عم نعيش ازمه ماليه
عالميه يلي هي اصلا بلشت عام 2008 مع فشل
عده بنوك في الولايات المتحده على راسها
بيرستارز ومن بعدها لمن برادرز دائما في
خوف انه يصير في عدوى على مصارف اخرى
يفشل مصرف هذا مش بس بيفشل المصرف لحاله
يعني زبائن عملاء المصرف ما عندهم اكسس
للودائع تبعهم يدفعوا اجور موظفين بقى
هيدا بياثر على كذا
كره ثلج يعني جلسه مش بس هيك في بنوك اخرى
او في حتى مؤسسات اخرى واضحه اموال لها او
منشفه على هذا
المصرفيناها
عندها وديعه بهذا المصرف او مثلا عند مثلا
يعني شركات ستارز حتى بالمنطقه نحن قبلنا
عدد منهم هم مستثمرين بشركات تكنولوجيا
الشركات عندها ودائعها بهذا المصير
بطريقه غير مباشره يعني ما عندهم يعني
معرضين للخطر
قولوها علينا طيبه
شو صار امبارح امبارح صار يخافوا انه بنوك
اخرى تكون منكشفه على هذا المصرف بطريقه
معينه ام بطريقه غير مكشوف عريانه ههه
[ضحك]
بعض الاشخاص منا فان الموضوع عشان كده اخذ
صعيد عالمي يعني
لانه مثل ما حكينا اذا عندك وديعه فوق
ال250 الف دولار سعره يخافوا انه لا لازم
انا قيمه بعدين
لهيك اضطر السلطات انه تقول
بالمصارف يلي
نهارين نحن رح نضمن كل الودائع بغض النظر
على قيمتها وهيك الاسواق واليوم شفنا انه
الاسواق هديه بلعب بتسجل الارتفاع يعني
مثل كانه هلا من الممكن الحديث بس مثل
كانه انه الازمه تراجعت بشكل
خطر على مصاريف اخرى خاصه المصاريف
الصغيره يعني في ترند عم نشوفه بالولايات
المتحده عم بيروح عملاء الصغيره يسحبوا
اموالهم ويحطوها بالمصارف الاكبر لانه هي
اقل خطوره خايفين هذا اللي كنت بدي اسالك
عنه انه نحن كافراد لما لانه شايفه كتير
ناس جالسين بيقولوا انه البنك اخطا في
استثماراته فالنتيجه كانت هذا الفشل وهذا
الافلاس يعني الحين احنا حاطين فيها
فلوسنا تخطئ في استثماراتها وتروحات رقبيه
لا هيك في جهات رقبيه وفي شروط صارمه على
ضمنيني بالله او حتى بس اقول لك ساره ليش
عم نفرق بالولايات المتحده بين البنوك
الاصغر والبنوك الاكبر بعد الازمه الماليه
العالميه يلي كان سببها انه البنوك عملت
استثمارات باصول سميناها توكسيك اصول منا
منيحه ابدا وهي قديت
الى هذه الازمه الماليه العالميه بعد بكم
سنه صار في قانون بالولايات المتحده اسمه
قانون دوت فرانك هو اللي بينظم عمل البنوك
وهو يلي بدع شروط شو هي نوعيه الاصول يلي
تحملها هذه البنوك بالعام 2018
بسبب لوبينغ من قبل البنوك الاصغر قالوا
لهم انتم ما فيكم تطبقوا علينا هذه الشروط
بالتالي خففوا شروط الرقابه على البنوك
الاصغر وعم بحكي البنوك الاصغر يعني قيمه
اصولها اقل من 250 مليار دولار ما زالت
بنوك كبيره ولكن بالمعيار الولايات
المتحده لذلك
قدرنا انه نشوف هالمشكله بشكل مفاجئ بدون
هذا البنك يكون عنده
رقابه اكثر على الخسائر اللي مني بها علما
مره اخرى بنذكر انه المشكله كانت انه اضطر
يبيع اصول
تاء يقدر يوفي طلبات السريعه للودائع لانه
في كثير عالم راحوا سحب سحبوا الودائع بس
هالاصول اللي باعه هيدي اصول جيده جدا وهي
اصول من المفترض انه تكون اصول بدون مخاطر
يعني مستندات تفاصيل
عندكم انتم احنا شفنا الفجعه بس والدعر
والانهيار
والعواجل وهذا كله على العموم انت طبعا
حتحكي في التفاصيل هذه اكثر في نشره
الاقتصاد نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كانت معنا زميلتنا في قسم الاقتصاد لارا
حبيبي اعتقد هذه يمكن اغرب مره تطلعي فيها
تغطي اقتصاد صح ههه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد من يومين عقد قران او قران
الاميره ايمان ابنه الملك عبد الله ملك
الاردن في حفل ملكي تابعوا العالم كله
اخباره وصوره وصلت كل انحاء العالم حقيقه
حتى من قبل الفرح يعني من وقت الاعلان عنه
وعن ترتيباته وفي اهتمام كبير فيه قبل
الفرح كان في حفله حنا انتشرت منا مقاطع
كثيره ووقتها في هذه الحفله ما ظهرت
الاميره سلمى اللي هي الابنه الصغرى للملك
عبد الله والملكه رانيا وشقيقه الاميره
ايمان وغيابها تساءل الاردنيين وغيرهم عنه
ولمن كثرت الاسئله طلعت مصادر مقربه من
العائله المالكه وصرحت للاعلام انه غياب
الاميره سلمى عن الحنه كان بسبب الدراسه
الجامعيه في الخارج وانها راح تكون حاضره
في الزفاف وفعلا من يومين شفناها في حفل
الزفاف الى جانب والدها ووالدتها واشقائها
اليوم الامير حسين ولي العهد الاردني فاجا
الاردنيين
للاشاعات اللي طلعت عن غياب شقيقته ولفت
الانظار بخفه دم فالامير نشر صوره له مع
خطيبته رجوى سيف وشقيقته الاميره سلمى
والصوره من الفرح وعلق عليها وكتب لقينا
سلمى وعلى فكره الملكه رانيا عملت ريبوسيه
كمان للستوري عندها ومن اكثر الاشياء
الملفته قبل الفرح كانت اغنيه خاصه نشرتها
الملكه رانيا بمناسبه زفاف ابنتها بصوت
اليسا وكلام ولحن مروان خوري وشكرتهم على
الاهداء وامس نشرت الملكه الاغنيه كامله
بعد ما كانت نشرت منها بس مقطع قبل ومعها
لما نشرتها كامله نشرت معاه كمان صور
وفيديوهات من الحفل والاغنيه للان محققه
مشاهدات مليونيه على حساب الملكه باكثر من
ثمانيه ونصف مليون مشاهده
على دربك
خطوه وخطوه تمشي
والنجم الليل بعرسك بايدك تقلب كمشي
ربي انت السامع
[موسيقى]
بدعي لاغلى
انساني يا ربي انت العادي ليلي بتسمع
دعواتك فرحك تحضن الايماني
للورد والياسمين
يا عروسه
[موسيقى]
يا امير
هالحلوين من
قول
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قالب
الدنيا في الواقع وعلى المنصات بسبب هجوم
عنيف شنه على رند سندس حاكم
على فكره يعني لكن في اخبار انه خلاص الان
بيستعد لسانطس لاعلان ترشحوا لي الرئاسه
وبالتالي حيكون منافس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني
لانه في 2018 ترامب اي الترشح ديسانس
لمنصب حاكم وبالتالي ترشحي للرئاسه الان
خيانه
التصريحات ترامب كانت في تجمع انتخابي في
ايون 10 دقائق نازل في ديسانتس لكن يبدو
هذه العشره دقايق برضو ما شافت غليله لانه
في الطياره وهو راجع من هناك سالو صحفيين
بعد الكلام اللي قالوا اذا هو كمان ندمان
انه دعم
فلوريدا في 2018 وتربق لهم نعم ندمان وقال
لهم نصا كان ميت مثل الكلب هذا الكلام
والله لترامب قال انه ديصانتيس كان كلب
ميت كان سياسي ميت ولولا دعمي له ما كان
صار شيء وكان زمانه الان بيشتغل في شركه
محاماه او بيعمل اي شيء تاني وما حد داري
عنه
[موسيقى]
من يناير من وقت ما تم الاعلان عن الصفقه
التاريخيه بين نادي النصر السعودي والنجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو والانظار
والاخبار
كيف تصدر خبر انضمام رونالدو لنادي النصر
الصحف العربيه والاجنبيه نصر نادي كبير
معروف محليا واقليميا واسيويا وانضمام نجم
عالمي بحجم رونالدو جذب الانظار لو من حول
العالم اكثر واكثر ومن وقت ما حط رونالدو
رجله في السعوديه وجماهير النصر من حول
العالم بتزيد يوم بعد يوم هذا غير محبين
النجم الا بداوا يتابعوا حسابات النادي
واليوم عدد متابعي النادي على انستغرام
اكثر من 13 مليون متابع وعلى حسابهم على
تويتر 4 مليون متابع اما على فيسبوك في
عدد المتابعين لحساب النادي اكثر من
مليونين متابع وعلى يوتيوب اكثر من نصف
مليون مشترك ويبدو انه تاثير رونالدو على
اداء النادي على منصات التواصل صار واضح
كثير ونشر موقع اسمه فوتبول بنش مارك مختص
احصائيات كره القدم احصائيه بتعكس تاثير
انضمام رونالدو على النصر من ناحيه
الارتفاع الكبير في اعداد المتابعين الجدد
على النادي اللي تربع على عرش قائمه افضل
النوادي اداء على المنصات واحتل النصر
المركز الاول في جذب المتابعين الجدد خلال
الشهرين الماضيين باكثر من تسعه مليون
متابع جديد خلينا نشوف مين باقي الانديه
اللي جاءت في قائمه فوتبول
[موسيقى]
واحده من اكثر الدول اللي منتشره فيها
عصابات المخدرات والجريمه المنظمه
المعروفه بالكارتير وهذه العصابات قويه
ولها نفود كبير يعني اكبر مثال على
الموضوع انه اليوم رئيس الدوله بيتهم اكبر
كرتل في البلد بانها مسؤوله عن انهيار
اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق نار عبر دعم هجمات
لعمال مناجم غير نظاميه عموما خبرنا يعني
انا بس بوريكم انه بدي ايش قوه وانتشار
عصابات المخدرات في كولومبيا عشان كده لما
يكون في خبر عن ضبط شحنه مخدرات في
كولومبيا بالمبدا يعني مو خبر مستغرب او
غير معهود يعني لكن تفاصيل شحنه اليوم هي
اللي حكايه مختلفه الصراحه فاللي صار انه
في وحده من او في وحده من البحريه
الكولومبيه كانت بتلف دوريات عاديه كده في
مياهها المحيط ولقي السفينه عايمه في وسط
المياه لوحدها يعني وقام وقفوه تفقدوها
لقوا فيها اربع اشخاص ميتين ومعاهم اكثر
من اثنين طن مخدرات
[موسيقى]
مشهد مثل الافلام والله يعني شفتوا
المخدرات كيف كده اكوام اكوام شفتوا كميه
عناصر الامن اللي بينقلوا فيها وداخل
السفينه كان في 2643 طن كوكايين السلطات
بتقول انها كانت في طريقها لدول امريكا
الوسطى ورغم انه بدايه حام التساؤلات
وشبهات حول موت الاربعه ركاب اللي في
السفينه لكن اتضح حسب السلطات انهم ماتوا
متسممين بغاز سام من عوادم السفينه يعني
ما في شبهه جنائيه يعني على فكره السفينه
يعني مو اي كلام باي كلام بنتكلم نحن عن
سفينه طولها 15 متر ارتفاعها منخفض وتوصف
بان شبيهه بالغواصات على العموم
مشاهدينا في امان الله